[Musique]
pas ce qui est bien quand on tourne avec
ses amis c'est que gilberte et surtout
on prend soin les uns des autres on se
respecte beaucoup
on va toujours essayer de s'encourager
au maximum pour tirer le meilleur de
chacun sans jamais se rabaisser celui-là
you
on fait donc et tout ça bien sûr en
gardant notre sérieux parce que faut pas
oublier qu'on est là pour travailler
[Musique]
salut les amis c'est la bande à fifi et
retrouver notre toute nouvelle comédie
nicky larson le parfum de cupidon et sa
soeur quand le 6 février au cinéma
monsieur larsen c'est vrai ce qu'on dit
sur moi ni personne vous êtes le
meilleur des gardes du corps
vous pouvez tirer si bâle au même
endroit
[Musique]
mon père était scientifique il a créé un
sérum d'amour
rendant irrésistible celui qu'il utilise
ce parfum une odeur rock chez celui qui
le respirons une explosion de
l'attirance émotionnel c'est n'importe
quoi ce parfum mais j'annonce un si ça
marche je change de sexe pour un plus
grand vraiment du mal être
il reste combien de temps pour retrouver
la mallette 47 eur qu'est ce que vous
foutez là vous on est venu vous et des
vêtements collet
non
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais